while authorities are still trying to
figure out what exactly happened
democrats in the media wasting no time
to turn the tragedy in texas political
the usual suspects mocking republican
ideas to harden schools and focus on
mental health listen
please spare me but don't politicize
this death bs to hell with anybody who
says don't politicize this it's time to
repeal the second amendment
oh you can't say that
well why not the guy called beto a sick
son of a [ __ ] the sick son of the
[ __ ]
were the ones up on that stage
that keep the freaks
the freaks on that stage what an
absolute fraud
the governor of texas is no amount of
bloodshed seems to be enough
for mega republicans oh i don't know
greg i've been following the coverage
pretty closely and it seems like
a lot of the conservative commentators
and the conservative politicians have
been talking about solutions
and a lot of the democrats in the
left-wing media have been attacking
republicans
well it's the when you don't have an
argument you go after the person and i
think that's what you always see with
morning blow they're just constantly you
know they have they they're they are
quite possibly the dumbest people on
television together they can't get one
brain cell so actually i'm doing exactly
what they're doing
the problem with this discussion is that
in a lot of political discussions you're
you're condemned if you have two
thoughts in your head you must have a
single variable thought right it's like
the dems can only scream its guns but in
the same regard the republicans might
just say it's the perpetrator when
actually these variables can intersect
you can say the person responsible for
this killing is that person that fiend
alone but having that rifle made him
more effective should we discuss that
should we try to test a ban i mean
geraldo's brought it up a bunch of times
and it's been around for a while raising
the age of the rifle to 18 to 21. i
don't see that as thoroughly irrational
especially if you put a
an expiration date on it so you can
compare three years or five years of it
against something else but the thing is
i mean why not address the root causes
because we it's just like those videos
that we did uh when we looked at george
floyd and and other people in these
police encounters we get there when it's
over and then we sit we pick it apart we
and we act like we're the experts but
these spectacles
even though they're not rare enough they
are rare enough that we can analyze each
one the way you can analyze those videos
and you will yield some common threads
whether it is untreated mental illness
whether it is bullying whether it is
broken homes whether it's lack of
security whether it is media
amplification which happens to be my
thing that i talk about all the time i
don't think it's right to keep doing
this all all the time but you can
actually come up with solutions if you
decide to entertain more than one
variable none of those people that you
showed are capable of entertaining more
than one variable they're stuck in one
rut and they will never get out of it i
we are at least able here on the five to
discuss the these things we can discuss
it and disagree they're incapable i'm
wondering if the media makes it
difficult for the democrats in
washington to compromise with
republicans to do a deal katie yeah i
think so first full disclosure i do some
social media work with vocors and
firearms and i've been a long time
second amendment advocate so as we're
talking about gun control important to
get that out there um but yes it does
make it harder for democrats who maybe
want to come to the table and have a
real adult conversation as you would say
about this issue and the arrogance that
we've seen from the media the majority
of them the ignorance that we've seen
from them they scoff and ignore and make
fun of real experts out in america who
understand what it's like to go and
bolster school safety who happen to be
part of the firearms community who know
what they're doing to keep kids and
their communities safe but because they
might be nra members or because they own
firearms they are ignored and therefore
the problem is never solved i've seen a
few things on things solutions that have
been offered the 21 age limit that just
got shut down in california they tried
to limit the purchase of firearms for
anyone under the age of 21
unconstitutional the issue of mental
health
this guy reportedly cut his face on his
own that is something that someone
should go to an institution for and if
you fill out a background check you are
asked and if you answer honestly if
you've ever been put into a mental
institution and if you say yes your
background check should fail he passed
that background check and finally i
would just say
politicians who sit around and say we
need to do something to do something
when they know it a won't work
and b tell people it will work that's
not productive that's lying that's
dishonest so work on things that will
actually
solve the problem and listen to real
experts not 99 of the people in the
media who have no idea what they're
talking about harold i'm wondering if if
you fill out a background check and you
just lie all over the background check
like countries if like hunter biden did
i mean if that's an effective background
check
of course not the look australia's had
one mass shooting since 1996.
uh they have brought about they've
placed public safety uh and public
health i think over some of the things
they prioritize it differently than we
have kitty i would differ with you on
on some of the things that you shared i
don't differ with you on your on your
passion and commitment to to gun safety
but think about this in most states it
takes you have to have hundreds of hours
of training to cut someone's hair to get
a license this young man in texas
apparently was able to get an ar-15 with
no training
i shared the data point a few minutes
ago
3448 days have been 900 shootings now
i think we should put all of them the
table and i'm one to believe i've tried
my hardest when i was in congress to
work with republicans to work with
liberal democrats conservative democrats
sometimes liberal democrats didn't want
to work with me because they thought i
was too conservative
the truth of the matter is we have to
figure out how you get more resource
officers in schools i walked past a
sneaker store today near my kid's school
they were two armed guys look like they
were navy seals outside that sneaker
store we should have that in every
school if we don't have
the wherewithal resources put aside the
partisanship everybody's got to come to
the table and figure out what have what
are we not doing to secure and make our
schools safe from these mass shootings
set aside subways and streets and others
our schools judge you and i have both
been dead have we been at that school
because of what happened there we have
to figure out also police officers and
police departments have to understand
what the protocol is when they go to
these schools
we should not as parents come to a
school and wonder who's in charge do you
guys know what you're doing that's their
job so there's so many things that need
to be put on the table here and simply i
would agree with you in this regard guns
is not the only thing but we are fools
if we don't believe we have to have a
serious conversation about how steps
reasonable and sensible steps we can
take
around public safety to deal with guns
judge you know one of one of the things
about guns is that when you look at
chicago i mean that is
that is just a fact
guns are illegal in chicago chicago has
more killings than we see anywhere else
in the country they have it every
weekend kids don't even run at the sound
of a gun all right so you know they want
to make this illegal and that illegal
but here's the problem
new york city was once the safest large
city not that long ago in the united
states the reason we're not safe anymore
the reason crime is surging is not
because of an increase uh it's not
because of covet it's not because of the
pandemic it's because these same people
and their social justice agenda have
decided that we gotta let everybody out
on bail let's not keep anybody in jail
even if we think they're a danger even
if they have a gun let's let them out
with their gun and in the end uh let's
demoralize and defund the police now
who's who is at risk the blacks the the
brown people everybody all the
minorities are at risk so this is all
politics and the fundamental problem we
have in this country is that the
politicians want to fight with each
other they don't want to solve anything
they could solve issues like immigration
they could solve issues having to do
with guns katie's right the ninth
circuit came down and said you cannot
tell us how old somebody has to be to
buy a gun that's a ninth circuit the
ninth circuit in california do you know
how liberal they are
so you know let's just get together and
recognize that these people are only
looking for the next election i like to
stand up for the white guy the white guy
like that neighborhood
speak for yourself
up next the far left and president biden
piling on police as liberal cities brace
for a brutal summer of violence
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now